stop whatever you're doing and listen to
me this is of the utmost
importance you look beautiful today but
that's not important right now there is
a new video out on geek and sunry where
I am with actual TV people people who
have been in actual film products that
are probably important and you can see
it right here right now check out
werewolves by Geek and Sundry I play a
guy who's married to Felicia Day how
about that seriously it's right there
it's awesome it's practically movie
quality you know it's not even going to
be this I'm actually going to show you a
CP of it so we killed Martha who was
clearly not the werewolf come on now
that was a super educated guest who has
that many cats and isn't a murderer
totally her fault no no not her fault
isn't that awesome it was like so well
done there was a huge crew there I've
talked about it before but I actually
got to see the final product and
everyone can see the final product now
and I'm trying to get as many of you
guys to go see it cuz it's totally worth
it I have like a multiple lines in it so
it's cool too so go check it out right
now um in other news this is very last
minute I am going to
BlizzCon yep that's this weekend and I
didn't know about it until about last
week um what happened was uh makeer
approached me with a deal because HP
approached me with a deal uh where they
were like hey do you want to go to
BlizzCon and play on our new laptop with
fans while you're dressed as a blood
elf and I was
like yes I have never been to BlizzCon
before and I would totally love to go I
mean I totally forgot that it was
literally an hour down south from where
I am I had no excuse for not going uh
and now I'm going to go there and I'm
going to be playing on uh hp's new
laptop that they just announced today I
believe uh and I'm going to be playing
with you guys who are there so if you
are at BlizzCon or you're going to
BlizzCon or you have an option to go to
BlizzCon I will be there uh Friday and
Saturday and I will be dressed as a
blood elf and I believe I'm not sure if
I'm going to be there dressed as a blood
elf both days but I will be playing
playing hearth stone with you guys and
uh all they asked is that I make a video
about it and I was like okay I'd love to
make a video playing with my fans
dressed as a blood elf playing on your
new fancy laptop so if you want to see
it be there or watch the video when it
comes out
later okay so that's actually all the
information I have I really don't have
anything else to say other than that you
look absolutely fantastic today but
that's unimportant there's no time you
have to get out of the building there
right behind you oh God they're right
behind
me can't you see them strangling me I'm
adding in get out of here
get I don't know what I'm doing what am
I doing with my life